warning the following video contains
spoilers is a freaking reaction video
what do you expect
previously on attack on Titan because I
didn't do a reaction for that episode oh
come on guys cheer up nobody likes a
bunch of Debbie downers
who doesn't love potato girl is that
even her real name I don't even [ __ ]
care every speech I think I came just a
little bit I've said this before for the
soundtrack is bloody amazing what the
[ __ ] are you so happy about
holy [ __ ] this is an amazing episode
welcome punch what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] why the [ __ ]
does he have a good haircut no this
Titan isn't gonna turn out to be Aaron
or something is it and now the
conclusion I mean acting like a [ __ ]
same [ __ ] different episode okay you
know you're a [ __ ] when you sound more
like a girl than the actual girl
standing next to you
Jesus Christ is Mikasa the only one that
can kill a [ __ ] Titan wait a minute
this is the perfect time to quietly
sneak around the Titans when they're
distracted we just need to make sure
that they don't notice us there not a
better time to talk about this why does
every Titan have the smile of a [ __ ]
rapist hi I'm johnny Knoxville and walk
into jackass dramatic punch that
tightened just faceplant himself into
the building even more dramatic punch oh
wow this quality of animation is freakin
amazing
shove the blade up there also a wait
does that mean
Titans have [ __ ] I don't know why I
randomly thought about that
rape face its that scene from the
opening she survived to some more
amazing animation so we get up potato
damnit
oh just kiss you - you know what here
let me help you move [ __ ] get out the
way
oh my god wait wait wait I'm gonna need
my phone for this I told myself I
wouldn't do another reaction for a while
but god damn stuff just keeps happening
dammit but hey there was another big
episode and a big twist at the end did
it did you see it coming I saw it coming
I mean when you have like a very
suspicious road Titan running around and
a main character they can't be dead I
kind of figured that you know the both
were connected but hey as for what I
thought saw Aaron turning out to be a
Titan well I'm kind of conflicted and I
think this is the episode where a lot of
opinions well would differ because I
said in my last reaction that they're
gonna have to do some kind of a spool of
some kind of day smacking awright see to
get out there's an Gaea giving the main
character this almighty power of
becoming a Titans kind of feels a bit
cheap and I wouldn't have actually
minded if Mikasa became the main
character yeah because in the last be
absurd she has been such a badass guards
and she's been like the star character
of the series so I'm kind of conflicted
about where this is gonna go but it was
amazing episode I'm just a bit worried
about where the writings gonna go from
here I mean I don't want it to be like a
Oh Aaron's inside to now so let's all
just rely on him because he's got all
the [ __ ] powers like some other
that's every other character except the
maid one is useless I hey I'll still be
flowing it so we'll just see how it goes
if media then I've already done some
other type enticing videos which you can
see right here and as always I'm
watching this on crunchyroll you can go
to crunchyroll.com slash the anime zone
for free for those premium membership
and you can find me on Facebook and
Twitter
in the description below so that's it
for me I've been gig up I hope you
enjoyed the episode and I hope you
enjoyed my reaction and until then I'll
see you all next time